we turn now to our next guest none other
than multiple Emmy award-winning actor
Kelsey Grammer he gained Fame for his
role as Dr Frazier crane on the hit show
Cheers ended spin-off Frazier his new
movie Jesus Revolution tells the true
story of an influential Pastor Chuck
Smith in the 1970s Smith famously opened
his church to hippies despite some
members being against it a Time Magazine
cover from 1971 called it the Jesus
revolution in this preview we see Chuck
played by grammar confront his daughter
about a mystery Street Preacher she
brought home take a look
what is going on you said he wanted God
to send you a hippie
I said that
but I did not mean it mean it Dad I am
telling you there's something about this
guy we talked all night he pretty much
blew my mind I spent the night with him
he could be an Ax Murderer anyone could
be an ax murderer look just listen for
10 minutes and if you think he's crazy
I'll throw him out myself
his house is a very good vibe
Vibe no
Kelsey Grammer joins us right now good
morning how you doing good morning I'm
great thanks guys thank you for joining
us now what resonated with you most
about this particular role in story well
when I um
I was having a sort of a late night and
I sat in my living room and I was
thinking geez I want to do something
that actually has some value Beyond just
the fact that I'm doing another role or
uh something that I enjoy playing and uh
the very next morning this script was
delivered to my house and uh
seems like Divine adults divided
intervention yeah yeah talk about timing
I didn't know this was a true story
though Kelsey did you know anything
about Chuck Smith well I knew about the
Time Magazine cover yeah I didn't know
about Chuck Smith yeah I knew about the
hippie Revolution or the Love Revolution
but I do not know this man's story and I
did know about Lonnie Frisby either
about his connection with uh each Coast
because I grew up in Florida and I met a
couple of girls on the beach once years
ago they said you know have you met
Jesus and I thought well
I said I think I kind of have
are you are you Jesus well I was I was a
a fairly religious kid now but I grew up
in a metaphysical church basically
Christian Science so uh it was a little
bit uh of a different take but I felt
familiar with it and I thought there was
such excitement in their eyes and such
such
um genuine uh innocence and and faith
and uh but they turned Chuck Smith
around though you said as a man you
connected to him because as a man sort
of at a loss that was very similar to
how you felt as well what do you mean by
that right well I think I think we've
all been through
crises of faith in our lives you know I
certainly lost my sense of faith for a
while through several things I mean I'm
working on a lot of I'm writing a book
about my sister actually right even now
uh because I'm still sorting through
something I lost your sister yeah and uh
all people stand on that sort of
precipice in their lives where they
suddenly need some intervention yeah and
then in Chuck's case of course it comes
through this this guy Lonnie frisbee
let's talk about the uh Frasier reboot
which is coming to Paramount plus we're
very happy about that of course part of
the CBS family Paramount Global um you
started production I think earlier this
month where does the life of Dr Frazier
crane pick up
well uh what's fun is it sort of we
wanted to make it another act his next
act because uh people used to ask me
when I was playing them for so long
before they would say how is it you uh
can keep this guy fresh I said well I
don't know you wake up in the morning
don't you
life is fine I feel fresh yeah yeah when
I wake up life isn't fresh each day for
you then I think you're sort of missing
stuff and so uh certainly the character
has that kind of uh uh buoyancy yeah it
really lives on it's an iconic role
character show
um was there hesitation because there's
there's a couple of ways that people
look at reboots it's like we gotta have
it and then there's also don't mess with
it right yeah well I'll tell you what I
sent off an email sometime in it was
late August where I said listen if we're
going to kill this character we've just
been given a bunch of notes on what they
thought the show should be and I wrote
David and I said uh if we're gonna kill
this character let me do it yeah because
what did you think of the news they were
they were awful you didn't like the
notes they were going down the wrong
path at the time right you know
well-intentioned of course noted to
death and I've I finally said look let's
just kill it now yeah and he said no no
sorry yeah we understand it's supposed
to be funny but Kelsey most notes when
people give you notes are well
intentioned yeah well I've gotten a
couple notes okay
I mean what's it like stepping back into
the character I mean do you feel the
character kind of coming out of you that
was seamless you know I mean I created
him I guess I mean you know the writers
you know the the idea of a writer a
writer creates a fantasy basically and
you come in along and put Blood and Bone
into it and uh that's where it arrives
your imagination and The Writers come
together to create this this thing that
ends up being real and uh he's uh he's
real and he's actually really funny so
he's really fun to watch him I like what
you said you put Blood and Bone in it
yeah you certainly do I'm telling you I
do not know anything about Chuck Smith
and I I saw this movie as a love story
of sorts did you did you as well yeah
absolutely everybody's looking for love
in it I mean you know what I miss that
generation yeah I love that generation
summer of love I love what we were then
I love the the hopefulness in people's
eyes and in their minds and in their
hearts I mean it was real it was genuine
and uh
we've lost our way somehow we really
have in a lot of ways you know we're at
each other's throats again and that just
seems like it just seems like the wrong
flavor yep yeah and I agree we can do
better well listen you're leaving a good
taste in our mouth today man we
appreciate you thank you so much for
joining your blood in your bones yeah
Chelsea Grammer Jesus Revolution is in
theaters everywhere February 24th all
right